I have never seen two people arguing
past each other coming to completely
different conclusions because they think
so completely differently quite like
Richard Dawkins and Jordan Peterson it
was as if they were speaking totally
different languages it was like watching
two men trying to work together to solve
a puzzle but one of them only speaks
German while the other only
speaks jazz or French poetry or Italian
opera fortunately they did briefly
address what I would regard as the hands
down Bar None most important issue they
could possibly address and we'll go
through that section apart from that
they were able to understand each other
on a few points but ultimately agreed
that their minds just don't work the
same like I do think that your
temperamental Tack and my temperamental
tack are are different they're gen
different you know we have a different
kind of mind I think the way that Dr
Dawkins and I look at the situation are
really quite different and at many many
many levels I think we just have to
agree that we have different kinds of
minds and you're interested in symbols
and I'm interested in facts Dawkins kept
insisting that he only cares about the
facts the facts that I care about are
the facts that are true and have
evidence I care about facts that has
nothing to do with the truth value and
what I care about is the truth value I
see no no truth value the truth of
science is the truth that gets us to the
Moon I'm not interested in Dragons I'm
interested in real in reality Jordan
Peterson by contrast focuses on stories
and symbols and meaning Dr Peterson
you're drunk on symbols yes you
mentioned i' i' I've heard your I've
heard that comment yeah yes we have to
prioritize the facts that's a value
hierarchy and that's all coded in the
story the reference I made to Harry
Potter the reference I made to the Lord
of the Rings and to The Avengers these
aren't casual references we see the
world through a story I think that at
bottom truth is Unified and what that's
going to mean eventually is that the
world of value and the world of fact
coincide in some manner that we don't
yet understand and it seems to me it's
not unreasonable to note that that's the
fundamental story of humanity but
Peterson made an important point about
facts there's no evidence whatsoever
from the scientific perspective that we
can Orient oursel in the world merely in
consequence of the fact sure and that's
a fact man does not live by facts alone
now for the most important part Dawkins
was arguing that scientific Enterprises
have the relevant credentials because
scientific claims have predictive power
and he wanted to know what similar
credentials something like the Bible
would have that's when Peterson Drew
attention to the fact that Dawkins
considers himself a cultural
Christian you made a statement a couple
of months ago that I found very
interesting and I don't claim to
understand it and I'm not trying to put
you on the spot with it you said that
you were a cultural Christian okay and
so that raised a number of questions in
my mind Dawkins has been calling himself
a cultural Christian for years but for
some reason it went viral more recently
so Peterson is probably referring to
some comments like this we are
culturally a Christian country I'm I
call myself a cultural Christian I love
hymns and Christmas carols and I sort of
feel at home in the Christian ethos I
feel that we are a Christian country in
that sense I find that I like to live in
a culturally Christian country and
Peterson thinks that if there's
something about Christianity that even
Dawkins likes maybe that's a kind of
credential it seemed to me that your
Proclamation that you were a cultural
Christian was a recognition um and a and
a statement that you had found something
in the culture that had been derived
from Christianity that you had an
affinity with Dawkins made it clear in
the cultural Christianity interview that
he thinks the claims of Christianity are
complete nonsense but he did sound at
times times as if he liked what we might
call the fruits of Christianity at least
more so than the fruits of certain other
ideologies if I had to choose between
Christianity and Islam I choose
Christianity every single time I mean it
seems to me to be a fundamentally decent
religion in so far as Christianity can
be seen as a bullock against Islam I
think it's it's a very good thing I in
Africa for example um where you have
missionaries of both faiths operating um
I'm I'm I'm on team Christian side as
far as that's concerned but does that
really mean Dawkins is giving a thumbs
up to Christianity well what do you
think that Christianity got right that
allows you to make a statement like that
I mean I know I know that there's
differences perhaps in what we both
think about the ultimate veracity of the
biblical stories maybe there isn't
differences like it would take a lot of
conversation to figure this out but but
what did you mean by that like what do
you think that Christianity got right
that would enable you to make a
statement like that virtually nothing
virtually nothing in your face
Christians I meant by that simp no more
than that I'm B brought up in a
Christian culture I went Christian
Schools I therefore know my way around
the Bible I know my my way around the
book of common prayer I I know I know
the hymns um that's all I I don't value
Christianity as a truth system at all as
as much as all the Dawkins drones were
cheering when he said what he really
meant by calling himself a cultural
Christian he's spouting nonsense here he
couldn't have simply been saying that he
went to Christian schools and that he
knows his way around a Bible because he
also suggested that Christianity is
better for the world than
Islam but Peterson pushes back okay so
let me let me ask you about that because
maybe that's true and perhaps it's not
so the first question is like do you
think that there any Market differences
between cultural Traditions that would
enable you to rank order them in terms
of their ethical validity yes I do so
Dawkins believes that you can rank
different cultures different systems
different ideologies based on their
ethical
validity I wonder what scientific facts
allow Dawkins to do this ranking
okay so for example we could contrast
mainstream UK Christianity with Islamic
fundamentalism okay so there's a
hierarchy there is a hierarchy notice
Dawkins just admitted that he's not
simply claiming that he went to
Christian schools and that he knows his
way around a Bible he agrees that
there's a hierarchy of systems some
systems are better than others some
systems are more ethically valid than
others but this raises a really really
important question in fact this may be
the most important question atheists
need to address in the world today
because until atheists can give a
serious answer to this question they're
going to be Paving the way for
Islam okay so there's a hierarchy there
is a hierarchy hierarchy that points to
what a hierarchy that points to
what let's say Islam is down here in
this hierarchy Christianity would be up
a little higher Dawkins would presumably
put in enlightened scientific atheism
much higher than Christianity or Islam
there's a
hierarchy what's that pointing
towards what makes Dawkins correct about
this hierarchy of ethical
validity what verifiable scientific
facts confirm
this
ordering there are two main
possibilities when Dawkins says this
system is better than that system and
this system is best he either means I'm
just giving you my personal preferences
here but there's really no correct
answer or he means that there's
something that makes his ranking
true if he's just giving his personal
preferences what would make the personal
preferences of Richard Dawkins more
valid than the personal preferences of P
didy or Andrew Tate or Ali
dawa if there's something that makes his
hierarchy correct what is it because
it's not
science I think what Peterson would say
is something like
this if there's a real hierarchy B is
really better than a c is really better
than b and so on then this hierarchy is
pointing to something and whatever it's
pointing to That's What I Call God but
let's see what Dawkins has to say again
here's the question okay so there's a
hierarchy there is a hierarchy hierarchy
that points to what and now for
Professor Dawkins uh well in the case of
Islam uh I dislike any religion which
punishes apostasy with death that throws
gay people of high buildings that
practices
clitoridectomy um
that that seems to me to place Islam on
a lower level than Christianity but
that's not to say anything very positive
about Christianity did you catch that he
dislikes some things about Islam in the
case of Islam uh I dislike I dislike I
dislike any religion which punishes
apostasy with death Dawkins gives a list
of things he dislikes about Islam
Muslims could give a list of things they
dislike about
atheism are we just giving lists of
things that we personally like or
dislike or is there something that makes
one set of likes or dislikes more
ethically valid than another set of
likes or dislikes well it might it might
be to say something positive about
Christianity like I think that question
is open because you might ask yourself
what did Christianity get right that led
it away from those particular
presumptions and towards something that
you regard as more ethically appropriate
like this isn't a trivial question it's
a very modest claim it's not a trivial
question at all it's an extremely
important question when Dawkins says
this system is better than that system
does he think his claim is true if so
what makes it true it's not science so
it's something else what is it what
explanatory resources does Dawkins have
available in his world view that can
account for this and if there's nothing
in his world viw that can possibly
account for what he believes he needs to
be made aware of that but as is so
frequently the case Dawkins misses the
point it's a very modest claim uh
there's not very much I mean to to be
better than a religion that throws gay
people off high buildings is not really
a
very virtuous achievement he just
doesn't get it he says being better than
Islam just isn't very impressive but
that's not the point if something is
better than something else what makes it
better your personal
preferences I I don't know I don't know
if that's true because if you look at
the barbarism that characterizes the
human past you might think that any
progression whatsoever towards something
approximating mercy and tolerance is
nothing short of a bloody Miracle true
it's impressive that people can improve
but now Peterson is getting a bit
sidetracked himself the real issue is
when we say that system X is an
improvement on system Y what do we mean
are we just saying what we personally
prefer or are we saying something that's
actually true if it's true what makes it
true but Peterson does point out how
amazing it is that we've gotten to a
stage where the improvements are taken
for granted and we think that it's just
obvious that our current way of doing
things is superior to more barbaric ways
of doing things well people are pretty
pretty ruthless and so are our
chimpanzee cousins yes they are right so
so we move forward into the light with
great difficulty and the fact that we
can take that for granted now and that
it seems self-evident and deserving of
faint praise it's it's not so clear to
me that that's that that's a reasonable
proposition okay as usual Dawkins not
only misses the point but derails it
completely let's let's Grant the faint
praise but that has nothing to do with
the truth value and what I care about is
the truth value I see no no truth value
in the claims of Christianity the Virgin
birth the Resurrection The Miracles do
you believe in any of those Dawkins only
cares about the truth and he doesn't see
how the claims of Christianity can be
true but he was being asked about
whether his claims about this being
better than that are true and if they're
true what makes them true and if they're
not true why does a person who claims to
only care about what's true care about
them he Dodges all of this and starts
criticizing Christianity again and his
fans love
it we've been asked asking the same
questions for years these aren't stupid
questions they're very very important
questions whose answers are crucial to
Western civilization as the world
changes but when we ask these very very
important questions atheists either
don't understand them or they Dodge them
or they give really really stupid
answers this issue that Dawkins and
Peterson briefly addressed accounting
for the hierarchy as far as I'm
concerned should have been the entire
focus of the discussion because the
complete inability of Dawkins to account
for his own views while pretending that
he only cares about facts is one of the
primary factors that's destroying
Western
Civilization I'll try to make this as
simple and clear as I can so simple and
so clear that even a few Dawkins fans
might finally be able to understand it
if you have one group that says we've
been commanded by Allah the creator of
the universe to violently subjugate you
to crush and humiliate you to conquer
your land and we will be rewarded with
virgins in
paradise and this group is coming
against a different group that says well
we personally dislike some of your views
our preferences are somewhat different
from yours but we can't even say why our
views are right so we'll just calmly
disagree one of those groups is going to
eat the other group
alive guess which group Dawkins is in
[Music]